arriving one of the prime minister's
longest serving critics tory predecessor
sir john major thank you
stepping up to make the case that this
prime minister's government is starting
to put the foundations of democracy at
risk
at number 10
the prime minister and officials
broke lockdown laws
brazen excuses were dreamed up
day after day the public was asked to
believe the unbelievable
ministers were sent out to defend the
indefensible
making themselves look gullible or
foolish
you are making an argument that the
prime minister broke the law you say
that people who mislead at the dispatch
box should resign
why are you not being plain with your
language today if the prime minister's
found he has deliberately lied it has
always been the case that prime
ministers resign on a visit to poland
boris johnson was asked about john
major's claim that he was shredding
democracy
i think i think that that
that is that is demonstrably untrue
sir john major made it as plain as he
could that he is unsure about boris
johnson's fitness to hold the office of
prime minister
in of itself that's not too much of a
surprise the former prime minister has
been a persistent critic of his
successor post-brexit
but what's different is that tory mps
today are less sure that they agree with
boris johnson over john major
many worry how far the current prime
minister will push attempts to cling on
to power today writing on his personal
website a tory mp first elected in 2019
said that the prime minister's actions
had been indefensible he said
i cannot and will not turn around to
those people or any of my constituents
who sacrifice so much look them in the
eye and insult them by trying to justify
or play down the events that have come
to light in the media and are now the
subject of a police investigation but
some tories defended boris johnson from
john major's attack saying the party had
changed from his day the conservative
party to the days when john major was
prime minister has certainly changed
there were no ethnic minorities in the
conservative party let alone
a handful of them being in the cabinet
at the top of government they're now
waiting for letters to drop from the
metropolitan police in the next few days
that'll go ahead regardless of the
changes at the top of the net there are
lots of people judging this government
right now sam coats sky news westminster